welcome to the presentation on the
pythagorean theorem i apologize if my
voice sounds a little horsey i was a
little hoarse not horsey i was singing a
little bit too much last night so please
forgive me well anyway we will now teach
you about the pythagorean theorem and
you might have heard of this before
as far as i know it is the only
mathematical theorem named after the
founder of a religion actually
pythagoras actually i think his whole
religion was based on mathematics but
i'm no historian here so
i'll leave that to the historians but
anyway let's get started on what the
pythagorean theorem is all about
if i were to give you a triangle
let me give you a triangle
and i were to tell you that it's not a
normal triangle
it is a right triangle
and all a right triangle is is a
triangle that has
one side equal to 90 degrees
and i'll leave you to think about
whether it's ever possible for a
triangle to have more than one side
that's 90 degrees but anyway just
granted that a right triangle is a side
that has at least well let me say a
right triangle is a triangle that has
only one side that's at 90 degrees
and if you if you have a right triangle
what the pythagorean theorem
allows you to do is if i give you a
right triangle and i give you two of the
sides we can figure out the third side
so before i throw the theorem at you let
me actually give you a couple of more
definitions actually just one more
so if this is the right angle in a right
triangle it's at 90 degrees and we
symbolize that by drawing the angles
like this kind of like a box instead of
drawing it like a curve like that i hope
i'm not messing up the drawing too much
the angle opposite
the right
angle or i mean the side
opposite the right angle is called the
hypotenuse
and i really should look up where this
word comes from because i think it's a
large and unwieldy word and
it's it's a little daunting at first my
sister told me that she had a math
teacher once who made people memorize
it's a high pot that is in use so i
don't know if that helps you or not but
over time you'll use the term hypotenuse
so much that it'll seem just like a
normal word although when you look at it
it really does look kind of strange
anyway going back to definitions the
hypotenuse is the side opposite the 90
degree angle and if you look at any
right triangle you'll also quickly
realize that the hypotenuse is the
longest side of the right triangle
so i think we're done now with
definitions so what is the hypot what
does the pythagorean theorem tell us
well let's call
c
is equal to the length of the hypotenuse
length of hypotenuse and let a
be the length of this side
and let b equal the length of this side
what the pythagorean theorem tells us is
that
a squared
plus
b squared
is equal to
c squared
now that's very simple formula might be
one of the most powerful formulas in
mathematics from this you go into
euclidean geometry you go into uh
trigonometry you can do anything with
this formula but we'll leave that to
future lectures anyway let's actually
test this formula or not test it let's
use the formula maybe another
presentation i'll actually do a proof or
a minimum a visual proof of it
i apologize ahead of time that i'm a bit
scatterbrained today it's been a while
since i left the video and once again i
told you i sang a little bit too much
last night so my throat is sore
okay so we have a triangle
and remember it has to be a right
triangle so let's say that this is a
right angle right here it's 90 degrees
and if i were to tell you that this side
is of length 4
and actually let me change that this
side is of length 3 this side is of
length 4 and we want to figure out the
side of this length
the first thing i do when i look at a
right triangle is i figure out what the
hypotenuse is which side is a hypotenuse
well there's two ways to do it actually
there's actually one way you look at
where the right angle is and it's the
side opposite to that
so this is the hypotenuse
this would be c
in our
formula on the pythagorean theorem i
mean we could call it whatever we want
but just
just for simplicity remember a squared
plus b squared is equal to c squared so
in this case
we see that the other two sides each of
them squared when they add it together
will equal c squared so we get 3
squared plus
4 squared
is equal to
c squared where c is our our our
hypotenuse
so 3 squared is 9
plus 16 is equal to c squared
is equal to c squared
and
c could be plus or minus 5 but we know
that you can't have a minus 5 length in
geometry
so we know that c
is equal to
5.
so using the pythagorean theorem we just
figured out that if we know the sides if
one side is three the other side is four
then we can use pythagorean theorem to
figure out that the hypotenuse
of this triangle it has the length 5.
let's do another example
let's say
once again this is the right angle
the side is of length 12
this slide is of length six
and i want to figure out what this side
is
so let's write down the pythagorean
theorem
a squared plus b squared
is equal to c squared
where c
is that length of the hypotenuse so the
first thing i want to do when i look at
our triangle that i just drew is which
side is the hypotenuse
well this right here is the right angle
so the hypotenuse is this side right
here
and we can also eyeball it and say oh
that's definitely the longest side of
this triangle so we know that a squared
plus b squared
is equal to 12 squared which is 144.
now
we have to figure
we know we have one side but we don't
have the other side so i got to ask you
a question does it matter which side we
substitute for a or b
well no just because
a or b they kind of do the same thing in
this formula so we could pick any side
to be a other than the hypotenuse and
we'll pick the other side to be b so
let's just say that this side is
b and let's say that this side is a
so we know what a is so we get
6 squared
plus b squared is equal to 144
so we get 36 plus b squared is equal to
b squared is equal to
see 144
minus 36
b squared is equal to
112.
now we got to simplify what the square
root of 112 is and what we did in those
radical modules probably is helpful here
let's see b
is equal to the square root of 112.
let's think about it how many times does
4 go into 112 4 goes into 125 times
it'll go into it 28 times
and then 4 goes into 28 seven times so i
actually think that this is equal to
times 7. am i right 7 times 10 is 70
plus 42 is 112 right
so b equals the square root of 16 times
7. you see i just factored that as a
product of a perfect square and a prime
number or actually doesn't have to be a
prime number just a non-perfect square
and then i get b
is equal to
square roots of 7.
so there we go
if this is 12 this is 6
this is
square roots
of 7.
i think that's all the time i have now
for this presentation
right after this i'll do one more
presentation where i give a couple of
more pythagorean theorem problems
see you soon